come on come on
[Music]
hahaha
ta-dah
[Music]
so
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
live
me
[Applause]
[Music]
hey
boo
ah
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]
fatality
the joker wins
[Applause]
the joker wins flawless victory
[Music]
brutality the joker wins flawless
victory
i'm so tough oh so cute
[Music]
flawless victory
my congratulations to the bride you know
about me and takeda
pain makes your fiance very chatty
[Music]
which realm do you hail from
it's funny you should ask that answer me
joker
[Music]
then make way for emperor joker
once a sidekick always a sidekick
my skills stand alone joker
you're an overripe second banana
[Music]
am i welcome here cowboy
like a porcupine at a nudist colony
well there's no need to be so prickly
[Music]
i can't kill you fast enough
my boy you can't kill me at all
i've had it with that shit-eating grin
[Music]
i will consign you to the coldest hell
let me put on my snow suit
prepare for your soul to freeze
[Music]
you are far from home
is it that obvious i'm a tourist
and that you're a danger to all
[Music]
you will go home joker
go home i just got here
and already the realms are tainted
[Music]
how is it no one has bled you out
cheating death is easy when you hold all
the cards
today i have the winning hand
[Music]
you know you remind me of bats
who is bats
just another jerk with no sense of humor
your chaos disrupts the hive
oh goody mission accomplished you will
die for your medley
i will banish you to chaos realm
chaos
now you're talking
be gone jester
[Music]
hell by your weight joker
as it should for the master of sick
burns
your lunacy must die
[Music]
i'm sorry are you slobbering
because i'm about to taste human flesh
the joke's on you
[Music]
i hear you do impressions
i am no cheap vaudevillian
it takes a lot of money to look this
cheap
[Music]
yo mommy dearest like stacking the deck
all existence adheres to cronica's
design
not once i start shuffling the cards
[Music]
i love the fenders do you talk to beds
a ludicrous suggestion jester
really i know a king who talks to fish
[Music]
the brotherhood of shadow is not
interested
trust me you could use some comic relief
you are beneath us joker
[Music]
so
what do i get for the price
chaos comes standard mayhem that's extra
what's the app charge for murder
we ready let's see a show of hands
we snap your balls
good luck trying to tickle my eyebrays
[Music]
i've seen better cosplay on hollywood
boulevard
what's wrong with my sartorial flare
step one admit you have a problem
[Music]
you may have the privilege of serving me
[Laughter]
did i say something funny
i'll never forgive you joker
which of my crimes has your panties
twisted
making chinos seem like less of a
monster
[Music]
time for a company move back to your
universe
i'm worried that i'll steal the show
that you'll dice me in the bite-sized
[Music]
i could have built something like you
you lack both the skill and intelligence
i don't know i'm pretty mean with
gadgets
this was my dream vacation i saw mayhem
mutilation it was all the gas
for a while
but these nincompoops they didn't really
get me
not even that pretty boy ninja mime good
night sweet prince
i'd finished just about everyone worth
finishing in earth realm and outworld
even lovable old netherrealm
i was a lonely heart in search of new
friends
but as luck would have it i had just the
gizmo to find them
and oh the hourglass spoiled me
havoc and i are going to be bosom
buddies
and what's that my new pal knows an
entire realm devoted to law and order
and he exists solely to disrupt it
well i say he and i need to get busy
meet the league of misunderstood maniacs
we're giving order realm an enema
and when we're done who knows where
we'll crash next
maybe we'll come to your house and slip
live grenades under your pillow maybe
we'll cut your favorite pets or maybe
we'll just break your tv right now
[Laughter]